حسب التقديرات فان الكسر المبكر عن سرطان
الثدي له فوائد هامه في طريقه العلاج
والتعافي منه فعند اكتشاف اورام الثدي في
المرحله الاولى تصبح نسبه شفائها اكثر من
95% ويمكن الكشف عن سرطان الثدي من خلال
نوعين من الكشف وهما الذات والسرير الفحص
الذاتي يتم اجرائه مره شهريا من قبل الشخص
نفسه ويكشف السرطان بنسبه 25% اما سرطان
عنق الرحم فهو السرطان الرابع الاكثر
شيوعا بين النساء في العالم وقدرت حالته
بنحو 600 الف حاله في 2020
فيما تشير منظمه الصحه العالميه ان تشخيص
المبكر لسرطان عنق الرحم يمكن ان ينقذ
حياه اكثر من 300 الف امراه سنويا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات